c'est un hôtel pas comme les autres en
plein centre de kiev une pouponnière
improvisée par une agence de fertilité
complètement débordé 76 alors à bhl
poupon nés de mères porteuses
ukrainienne depuis le début de la
pandémie est pris en charge par des
nourrices en attendant que leurs parents
biologiques puisse enfin venir les
chercher
et parmi eux il y a le petit ignacio
unis le 29 avril ses parents venus de
l'argentine l'ont vu que sur vidéo et
dans quelques minutes ils pourront enfin
le toucher un moment d'extase pour andré
sa maman
tout comme si des mois d'angoissé venir
s'envoler son talent comme de plus en
plus de couples infertiles andrea et
hernando ont décidé de se tourner vers
l'ukraine où la gestation par autrui
rémunéré est non seulement légal
mais parmi la moins chère au monde les
mères porteuses souvent issus de milieux
pauvres peuvent gagner jusqu'à 25000
dollars
mais la pandémie et ses images de bébés
un enfant coincé en ukraine apatrides
pendant des semaines a révélé à quel
point c'est devenu une industrie
lucrative des usines à bébés selon des
groupes de défense des femmes les images
ont aussi choquée cette spécialiste
canadienne en droits reproductifs qui
voit un manque flagrant de compassion de
la part des autorités de l'ue craint
elle dit qu'au canada où les mères
porteuses n'ont pas le droit d'être
rémunéré 60 bébés dont les parents
génétiques et l étranger sont nés
pendant la pandémie et c'est elle
l'avocate qui a convaincu rapidement
gouvernement trudeau de les laisser
entrer au pays
mais en ukraine le dénouement est loin
d'être si ça car contre ces bébés
visiblement bien soigné pour qui on a
même organisé une cérémonie d'adieu il y
en aurait d'autres des centaines qui
attend d'être réunis avec leurs parents
nous pour andrea c'est une nouvelle vie
qui commence
reste plus qu'à trouver comment rentrer
en argentine mais cette fois ce sera le
coeur léger
son enfant dans les bras ici tu as marre
altérait secoue radio canada montréal